Samsung is officially
discontinuing
their Galaxy Note 7 smartphone
'cause they've been randomly
bursting into flames,
like grandma falling asleep
with a cigarette in her mouth.
-(laughter)
-Let it go. She's gone.
Combine a Samsung...
combine a Samsung
with a hoverboard
and discount vape pen,
and you've got a great ensemble
for that hip,
tech-savvy millennial
-who loves being on fire
all the time. -(laughter)
But there are some brilliant
Grand Theft Auto modders
who have added the Galaxy
to the game's weapon store.
-Take a look.
-(laughter)
-♪
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
HARDWICK:
Ah.
Mwah. Mwah.
I mean, sure, you know,
it looks dangerous,
but at least
it has a headphone jack!
No, I have not been mad
about this for too long!
You haven't been mad
about it long enough!
I mean, yeah,
I have iPhone 7 Plus,
and the pictures are amazing,
particularly in low light,
but I just want headphones,
which is why God put two holes
in a phone!
It's headphone jack,
not headphone and Steve!
-(laughter)
-Comedians, uh, this looks...
-What just happened?
Comedians... -(laughter)
This looks really bad
for Samsung,
but they are the world's
biggest smartphone maker.
So, can they come back
from this scandal?
-Ron Funches. -Oh, yeah.
They'll be just fine.
-(laughter) -Like,
I don't know if you noticed,
but this entire year
has been a Dumpster fire, so...
HARDWICK:
Yeah, that's true.
-(laughter)
-That's true. Yeah, points.
Uh, Al Jackson.
Dude, they got to spin it, man.
Samsung's got to be like,
"Look, this only happens
to our phone
if you like your own statuses
on social media."
-Yeah, that's a great idea.
-(laughter, applause)
-Points. Bobby Lee. -Of course,
they're gonna survive.
They're Korean like I am,
and we created "Gangnam Style."
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
Points. -(applause and cheering)
Yup.